let's say we're a professor at a
university of a statistics class and we
administer an exam and we're curious
about the relationship between the
amount of time that students study and
the percent that they get correct on the
test so what we do is we grade all of
the exams we set up these buckets the
time studied 0 to 20 minutes 21 to 40
minutes 41 to 60 minutes or greater than
60 minutes so those are our buckets for
the amount of time studying and then we
also create buckets for the percent
correct so 0 to 19 correct to 20 to 39
percent correct 40 to 59 correct 60 to
correct or 80 to 100 correct and then we
figure out what percentage of our entire
student population falls into each of
these categories so for example two
percent of our students studied 21 to 40
minutes and got between 80 and 100 on
the exam 16 studied for more than an
hour more than 60 minutes and got
between 40 and 59
on the exam so what i have right over
here this is a two-way table it's
describing a joint distribution the
joint the joint distribution between you
can view these as two variables the time
studied and the percent correct
now what we're going to introduce
ourselves and this introduce ourselves
to in this video is two new ideas
outside of just the joint distribution
one is the idea of the marginal
distribution i will write this in green
marginal
distribution
and this is the idea of okay i can see i
can i can break down my uh
my class based on both of these
variables but what if i only care about
one of if i if i care about the
distribution of just the percent correct
i don't want to break it down by time
studied
well if i want to if i want to figure
out the distribution of percent correct
i could just total up each of these rows
and i would end up
i would end up with this distribution
right over here
and just to make it clear i would see
that
i would see that 20 percent of my
students got 180 to 100 percent correct
i would see that 30 percent of my
students got between 60 and 79 correct i
see that 35 percent of my students get
between 40 and 59 percent correct i
think you see where this is going 10 of
my students got between 20 and 39
correct and then finally five percent of
my students got between zero
zero and nineteen percent correct all we
did is we totaled up each of these rows
and notice these now add up to a hundred
this is this describes the distribution
of the scores in my class if someone
were to just give you this column you
would say okay 20 of my students got 80
to 100 percent you don't know the
breakdown by how much they actually
studied you'd say five percent got
between zero and nineteen percent on my
test but you wouldn't know what the
breakdown of that five percent based on
how much they studied
so this type of distribution it's called
a marginal distribution well because you
can view it as it's written in the
margin right over here that we total
these we total these rows and we write
it in the margin now there's another
marginal distribution we could figure
out the distribution of the amount of
time people studied in my class and so
if we cared about that that we would
total up each of these columns
we would total up each of the columns
and look at this right over here we'd
say okay seven percent of my class
studied between 0 and 20 minutes 15
percent of my class studied between 21
and 40 minutes 43 of my class studied
between 41 and 60 minutes 35 of my class
studied more than 60 minutes more
more than an hour and if i just look at
this marginal distribution this marginal
distribution of the time studied i'm not
able to get the breakout of that 35
percent that studied more for more than
an hour if i just looked at that
marginal distribution once again it's
called that because i'm writing in the
margin in this case below our table
if i just looked at that marginal
distribution i would not know the
breakdown by the actual percent correct
now there's another type of distribution
that's related to these joint
distributions or you could say these two
way tables and that's thinking about the
distribution of one variable given what
bucket you fall in for the other
variable so let me write this down so
if i want to say the distribution
distribution
of
scores
of scores
given
all right let me write it this way
distribution of scores among
among those
who
studied
studied let's say more than 60 minutes
so where would i get that well it's all
right i'll go to the column of the
people who studied more than 60 minutes
and then i'd find this distribution of
scores and i see it right over here
among the folks who studied more than 60
minutes
i have this distribution
of scores so in that group 10 got 80 to
100 5 got 60 to 79 16 percent got 40 to
none of them zero percent got 20 to 39
and four percent got zero to 19
and so this distribution of one variable
given a bucket that you're falling into
another variable this is called a
conditional distribution because you're
getting a distribution conditioned on a
value of another variable so this right
over here is a
conditional
distribution
so the big idea here you have this 2a
table we're trying to relate how two
variables well how we're trying to study
how two variables relate to each other
if we care about just the distribution
of one of the variables for example the
time studied we can sum up the columns
here and we would get this marginal
distribution if we cared about the
distribution of percent correct we could
sum up the rows and get that
distribution and if we wanted in the k
in the case that i just talked about the
distribution of one variable
the distribution of one variable in this
case the distribution of scores the
distribution of percent correct given a
certain value conditioned on a value of
another variable well that's going to be
a conditional distribution